great so I'm really excited to be
talking to you today I've had amazing
conversations so far and it's gorgeous
campus as I'm sure you all know and
appreciate every day
so the talk is set against the backdrop
of the ways that new technologies are
shifting the landscape of healthcare so
people are using new devices to collect
and interact with their data from
activity trackers for general health and
wellness to smart glucose monitors to
ingestible medications instead
ingestible sensors that track your
medication patterns we're using
technology to access our health
information online forming communities
with others who share our conditions
connecting to clinical data through
patient portals and personal health
records and connecting to healthcare
professionals whether through online
messaging or telemedicine one population
that's seen as especially well-suited
for these new health technologies are
older adults we're seeing an increase in
the aging population worldwide the
population of people aged 60 and over is
expected to double by 2050 from the
number in 2015 and in response to
Caravan caregiving shortages and older
adults as frequent users of health care
there is a growing industry funding
health technologies for aging and one
estimate saying we'll see the number
going from 2 billion to 30 billion in
the next few years and governments
internationally are funding research on
technology to support older adults in
living healthier lives we're seeing
technologies to help older adults live
longer at home such as smart medication
dispensers interfaces that support
caregivers and family members in
monitoring medication adherence activity
daily activities of daily living acute
events such as Falls and also
technologies to support older adults
social interactions whether with family
and friends or even with artificial
intelligence so at the same time as
we're seeing exciting technology
development in this
area we are also seeing a lot of
rejection of this technology by older
adults not using the technologies that
are so carefully designed for them so
the literature has attributed this to
things like lack of usefulness the
technologies aren't meeting the real
needs of older people expense
experiences past experiences or lack of
experience with technology but the one
I'm gonna really focus in on for this
talk is the ways that stigma and
assumptions of technology designers
affect technology design and the way
technology is received by older adults
um in research and in the media in the
discussion of the increase in the number
of older people worldwide we often see
this kind of doom and gloom language the
idea that the demographic shift that
we're experiencing is this unwelcome but
unavoidable event the term gray tsunami
has been thrown around to describe the
kind of oncoming onslaught of the older
population researchers discuss older
adults discuss how older adults are
sometimes seen as a homogeneous
population defined by physical and
cognitive decline seen as a burden on
the resources of younger people aging is
sometimes posed as a problem to which
technology is the solution and at the
same time older adults are often
described as unwilling or unable to use
these technologies even when research
has shown this to not always be the case
the negative ways of thinking about
aging affect not only technology
designers but are also internalized by
older people themselves so some studies
have found that older adults reject
technologies such as Life Alert devices
that have been marketed to older adults
and signified dependence and frailty so
here we see ideas around health aging
and technology coming together to affect
the ways that technologies are designed
for older people and the ways that they
are received by them my research lies at
the intersection of health technology
and aging
to inform my work I draw on critical
theoretical perspectives from
human-computer interaction drawing on
literature that points the importance of
a shift from designing to compensate for
perceived deficits to designing to
empower social justice oriented design
and feminist human-computer interaction
which emphasized the importance of
researchers reflecting on their own
assumptions about populations and how
they affect the design process and I
also draw on perspectives from social on
critical gerontology ageism is a term to
describe how aging is often described as
a period of decline rather than of
continued opportunity the social
construction of dementia perspective
points out how the ways that we think
about dementia often focus exclusively
on structural changes in the brain
rather than the major impact of the
social environment has on our day-to-day
lives and keeps walkers prescribe
disengagement advances this view helping
us understand the ways that people with
dementia upon receiving a diagnosis are
often told to go home and get a power of
attorney and wait for death and we don't
really think about ways to help people
at dementia self manage their condition
or find new opportunities as their
abilities change so I'm going to talk
about three projects today where I draw
on the lenses I discussed to examine
technology first we're going to look at
robotic pets as one instance of a health
technology to understand narratives of
Aging then I'll present some work
analyzing how health and aging shape the
ways ideas about health and aging shape
the ways that older adults engage in
activities and what this means for
technology design in this area and
finally I'll talk about a context in
which these narratives of Aging and
dementia in particular are challenged so
first starting with this project looking
at robotic pets so why look at robots
well robots are one of those categories
of technology that's being designed to
support the aging population in part
motivated by a lack of caregivers
available to provide care for people as
they age
robots designed for this population
include healthcare robots for
rehabilitation medication delivery
assistance with home tasks and also
companion robots which are intended to
provide social interaction or recreation
there is a growing industry as well as
national initiatives around robots for
older adults and also a lot of popular
media interest in how robots can provide
support to older adults we did a study
further delving into the media
characterization of robots for
healthcare through a discourse analysis
of YouTube videos uploaded by a variety
of organizations including healthcare
organizations in these videos Hospital
organizations explain that robots could
not and would not replace staff in many
settings because of the compassionate
nature of care that patients expect and
deserve
but in nursing homes on the other hand
robotic pets were often presented as
having this almost magical ability to
comfort and provide therapy to patients
such as older adults with dementia so at
the same time as we see these
initiatives and this kind of positive
media discourse around robots for older
adults there are studies describing
older adults rejection of robotic
technologies again we see rejection
attributed to things like age gender I'm
not meeting the needs people have or
preferences for some tasks and not
others but again let's return to this
idea around stigma and assumptions of
designers so specifically in regards to
robots some studies have found that
older adults will distance themselves
from robots that appear to have been
designed for frail or isolated older
adults these studies have also found
that even when research and researchers
and designers attempt to engage in the
appropriate user centered design process
right talking to the end user
interviewing older adults about their
needs they inadvertently end up
prioritizing the needs of staff and of
caregivers and of their own assumptions
about aging even when this contradicts
the things that the older adults are
telling them so to understand the
disparity between the ways that robot
talked about for older adults and the
ways that older adults appear to respond
to these robots we did a study asking
how to older adults envision the role of
robots in their lives how do their
preferences differ from assumptions made
by robot designers we conducted eight
focus groups with 41 participants at
community centers and independent living
communities we brought six examples of
existing robotic pets to stimulate
discussion and we took a grounded Theory
approach to analyzing our data I'm going
to talk about three points that came out
of these focus groups in terms of how
robots are often designed the kinds of
assumptions about older adults that
might be informing these approaches and
what the participants desired in our
focus groups so robots are often
designed to provide companionship to
older adults there can be the assumption
that the older person is isolated
without a potential for a human company
and the robot is supposed to serve as
the relational partner in interaction
but most participants rejected the idea
of having a robot just to provide
company and instead they wanted to use
the robotic pet to augment their
existing social networks such as having
another topic to talk about with their
their husband or meeting new neighbors
they would look outside their window and
see people walking their dogs past them
and they couldn't have dogs in the
retirement community they lived in so
they brainstormed how it would be fun to
have a robotic pet that they could walk
to the dog park to hang out with
everyone else I'm one person even spoke
about taking the robotic Pat on walks to
meet people to date one of the main
reasons that robotic pets are often
described as appealing to the older
population is that they don't require
maintenance and some participants
explain that unlike a live pet they
could never see themselves forming a
relationship with a robot so they could
just imagine using it for functional
assistance but for the people who could
envision themselves forming emotional
relationships with these robots they
talked about how reciprocal functional
assistance is actually woven into our
relationships with other people they
expressed the desire to be able to take
care of the robotic pet in some way and
finally robotic pets there's there's a
kind of ongoing debate in the literature
about robotic pets for older adults with
concerns around tricking and with one
kind of key robot assists in the field
saying is it ethically justifiable to
aim to create robots that people bond
with for example in the case of elderly
people are people with special needs and
we might see how this idea is based on
an assumption of older adults is unable
to make their own decisions and
participants spoke about possessing the
ability to give in to the fiction so
they talked about how one participant
spoke about her kind of ongoing
relationship with Star Trek characters
and this shows that she watch she knew
that she didn't actually have
relationship with them but she kind of
had this fiction other spoked about
stuffed animals
many people have stuffed animals and
don't actually think of them as live
pets but you might wave to it as you
walk in the house or have little
conversations with it now and then so in
this project we see the way our
narratives of aging are coming through
in our technology design but how they
might miss align with the actual
experience of older adulthood
understanding this can lead to exciting
new design directions designing for
topics between long married spouses I'm
thinking about romantic opportunities
for the aging population and now I'm
going to complicate the story a bit so
I'll talk about the ways that
conceptions of health and aging affect
the ways that older adults themselves
engage in mundane activities
specifically leisure activities and how
this actually fits into these kinds of
merging and ongoing debates about
designing technology for the aging
population so the robotic pet work that
I just spoke about actually fits into
this larger conversation about
technology design for older adults
researchers are discussing how there
appears to be an overemphasis on health
for the aging popular
in particular and over emphasis on
physical and cognitive decline as
neglecting the full picture of what it
means to grow older and as this
conversation develops we're seeing a
growing focus on technology for other
purposes in academic literature things
like financial I'm gaming creative
engagements so this study trying to
follow in that path took on the topic of
leisure activities and we adopt Stebbins
definition of leisure activities as
uncoerced activity engaged in during
free time which people want to do and
either a satisfying or fulfilling way so
what do we already know about leisure
activities well we know that they are
beneficial throughout the lifespan and
in older adulthood they can provide a
platform for self-expression and
personal fulfillment and also be helpful
during difficult times and transitions
we also know that leisure activities
change as people age people engage
lesson activities like traveling but
continue to engage in the same amount
with activities such as listening to the
radio so in this research we seek to
answer two questions such as what
factors influence participation in
leisure activities and how do older
adults decide which activities
constitute leisure activities in order
to inform technology design in this area
so for this study we conducted two hour
interviews in participants homes and we
went to their homes so that we could
actually see them engage in some of
these activities we observe them and
took pictures and we took again we took
a grounded Theory approach to analysis
I'm with of interviews with 24
participants so I'll just provide a very
quick overview of the leisure activities
people described just so you could keep
it in mind through the rest of this talk
so the vast majority described watching
TV reading and playing games many
described computer use in tracking with
pass gardening writing and learning and
then some people had
really unique activities such as one
woman with a life-long button collection
the finding from this study that I'm
going to talk about today is ways that
predominant societal narratives and
attitudes towards aging this idea of
healthy aging in particular affect how
participants engage in leisure
activities so though some people were
very certain about considering physical
and cognitive exercises not to be
leisure activities many others actually
selected leisure activities in order to
preserve physical and cognitive
abilities something that we click really
refer to as the use it or lose it
mentality people describe doing
activities like mahjong crossword
puzzles even learning Japanese for brain
health and movement based activities
yoga I'm pool aerobics I'm in order to
preserve physical functioning and this
was done in a pretty intense way so um
there's a sense of gripping tightly onto
existing abilities fighting the signs
and symptoms of aging like with p22
shown here I'm working on a crossword
puzzle explaining that these puzzles
start easy on a Monday if I can do a
Saturday I feel like I've conquered the
demons of old age people directed this
idea that negative signs and symptoms of
aging could be fought if we only work
hard enough outwards to others as well
as inwards towards themselves so p22
that participant with the crossword
puzzles told me that she has a friend
who is starting to have trouble
remembering things
she told this friend that she should
start doing crossword puzzle to fight
off these changes and she also described
her reaction when her friend refused to
take her advice she says I get angry
when I see people that have this problem
and they don't do anything about it we
can turn to scholarship from critical
gerontology that talks about how seeing
people as entirely responsible for
maintaining their own physical and
cognitive abilities can be problematic
because it shifts attention away from
responsibilities that we may have as
society to provide equitable access to
resources to let people age without
stigma to include people of all ages and
opportunities for lifelong learning a
second way that we found narratives of
aging affect how people think about an
approach activities was in this concept
of age-appropriate activities this
includes ideas around activities that
older adults should or should not engage
in so as one example participants seem
to be responding to this kind of
dominant idea that there's not really a
point in older people continuing to
learn so some use this to explain why
they didn't learn anymore but others
ignored the idea almost in a defensive
way such as p13 who said even at my age
I still enjoy learning and participants
demonstrated their awareness of negative
expectations or ideas about older adults
sometimes telling me how different they
were from those people in the
stereotypes the people that live down
the hall from them
ptoo told me about how basket weaving
was an activity that they did in the
place that he lived he said that he
really wasn't interested in this I've
seen too many pictures on TV where all
the older people are sitting in there
doing this and I'm not ready completely
for that yet he described how he was
quite excited that back timmy director
had actually bought a computer and was
looking forward to engaging in that
activity so in this example we can see
how in some cases leisure activities are
seen as negative and rejected just
because they're associated with older
people and at the same time these
activities are thought of as something
that one might need to do in the future
as soon as they reach a certain age even
if it doesn't actually suit any
individual personal interest so even
though we chose leisure to move away
from health and ageist assumptions we
actually found that ideas about health
and wellness are intertwined with the
ways that older adults select the
activities that fill their time we argue
that in responding to recent challenges
to technology designers to
human-computer interaction
kurz to move away from dominant medical
models we have to take a nuanced view
that has space for people's own
motivations about their health even if
they come in part from these
internalized societal narratives that we
might be simultaneously trying to
dismantle we can also reflect on the
focus of our interventions for ageing
targeting individuals to support
activities I'm engaging in activities
could be really useful but it shouldn't
be our sole target or we might end up in
a place where we can see how someone
might blame their friend for developing
cognitive impairment because they
weren't working on enough crossword
puzzles so we can call attention to and
expand computing research calling
attention to the many other factors that
affect older adults quality of life and
well-being access to medical care and
assistive technologies affordable
transportation and walkable sidewalks
understanding how technology contributes
to and might dismantle stigma around
aging and finally we can think about how
our very presence or engagement with a
research topic can position older people
in a negative way so I realize now that
me a younger person going in and asking
all these older people about the leisure
activities they do is not actually a
neutral situation for them people felt
the need to tell me how busy they were
I'm even defending some of their
activities to me and we can imagine how
this happened similarly with a range of
other topics that we're very interested
in when it comes to aging things like
frailty talking about people's cognitive
abilities and changes that they're
experiencing in relation to them
thinking backing thinking back to that
person who didn't like that basket
weaving how even letting someone know
that you think about them as an older
adult might put them in a particular
position other interacting with you so a
useful starting point might involve
reflecting on the language we use the
age diversity of our teams and the
perspectives that we have that shape our
projects yes
sort of rejecting the group affiliation
as being say elderly yeah you know I can
obviously see myself but other other
groups that they instead identify it
with sorry I'm not elderly I'm something
else I don't remember any other I think
just the way that anyone might write so
if it was a person who's interested in
technology I'm a person who's interested
in technology it's an artist they might
say I'm an artist so I'd say that but
it's it's really consistent with a lot
of research projects where no one ever
wants to be associated with older people
so they say oh this technology I would
never use this but actually my mother
would have loved it when she was older
even if the mother they're thinking of
was actually younger than they are now
right or people talk about the person
down the hall that this would be great
for who's more frail or older than they
were so I talk about a case where we see
narratives of Aging permeating the ways
that older people live their lives and
now I'm gonna present a context in which
these narratives around aging and
dementia in particular are challenged so
the narratives of Aging that position
older adults as isolated and emphasized
physical and cognitive decline are
amplified in dementia so dementia is an
umbrella term for conditions such as
Alzheimer's disease vascular dementia
Lewy body dementia and it's a condition
that we so often I'm characterized by
changes in memory language judgment and
problem-solving but a lot of the day to
day quality of life when you are living
with dementia is actually significantly
affected by other factors on this social
environment how you are seen and treated
by others and the services that are
available and the support that you
receive so in the past we've looked at
how others art therapists in particular
counter negative narratives of dementia
for example the way that they
contextualize the expressions of people
with dementia when sharing with others
such as family members
highlight significance of what's being
said and to avoid misinterpretation of
others how they create spaces through
art exhibits for the voices of people
who are so often not heard or valued by
others but I've become increasingly
interested in the way that people have
dementia themselves might be or might be
supported in doing the same work and we
might see this idea as fitting into a
bigger picture topic that's growing in
the field of human-computer interaction
around health activism so health
activism is an attempt to change the
status quo including social norms
practices and policies is different from
health advocacy which focuses on
Education and works within the existing
system and biomedical model so Parker
proposed health activism as a way to go
beyond the focus on individual
determinants of health for marginalized
populations that face disproportionate
barriers to health and human computer
interaction but even as this interest in
this topic grows we don't have a lot of
cases of health activism yet or in
understanding of how different instructs
infrastructures might support or
constrain engagement in this kind of
activism so I'm going to present a case
of health activism of people with
dementia happening through an
organization called dementia Diaries so
with this organization people with
dementia called diarists call in to a
number on their phones to leave a
recording which is then posted online to
the website and sometimes to Twitter as
well so to understand what's going on
here we had the following research
questions how do people with dementia
take an active role in challenging
narratives of dementia how can
technology support vulnerable
expressions of people with this
condition
so 14 diarists with dementia three
supporters which might be caregivers in
one case a translator and two
facilitators consented to be a part of
this study which involved the
observation of a three-day gathering I'm
held by this organization that I attend
in the UK where I also did in-depth
interviews with attendees the average
dyrus age was 60 years and I will point
out that this reflects that the majority
of people were diagnosed with early
onset dementia which is defined as
dementia diagnosed before the age of 65
so this population is definitely skewed
younger and then the majority of those
with the condition and I'll also note
that though we do not measure cognitive
status or ask people about the stage
they were in you can think of people in
the study as in about the mild to
moderate stage so people face some
challenges with daily activities almost
all were retired from work they needed
varying levels of support to attend the
event but people were very much able to
engage in complex discussion to express
the important things that they care
about verbally and to consent on their
own to take part in this study so unlike
other important work in the health space
the goal here is not primarily social
supports or seeking and sharing health
information instead it is to change
attitudes as the facilitator or the
program told us the goal of dementia
Diaries is to bring the real and raw
voice of people at dementia to a wider
audience and by doing that to influence
attitudes and understanding so the real
and raw voice is the unshaped authentic
concerns and priorities of people at
dementia is the mechanism that's
intended to raise awareness so at first
this doesn't seem special raising
awareness of dementia is actually quite
common goal of a lot of organizations
often about the signs of dementia to
support earlier detection or about the
pervasiveness the severity the tragedy
associated with the condition so what
are people raising awareness about on
dementia Diaries well it comes down to
showing that people with dementia have
their humanity p5 says yes you may have
dementia but you're still a person I'm
pretty significant in a condition that
we so often associate with a loss of
self
p8 talked about making a diary about his
train ride to the gathering about how he
and his fellow riders were just having a
normal conversation laughing and how
just seeing these kinds of mundane
experiences can actually radically
change attitudes of others about what
people at dimetric can and can't do and
being able to call in and leave a
recording about an experience anytime
anyplace was quite accessible to people
dementia a condition where the ability
to recall events becomes increasingly
difficult but the wish to change
perceptions of dementia also brought up
some tensions with this intent of
sharing the real and raw right the
mechanism that's supposed to be what
influences attitudes and today I'll just
share one example
so people strove to share positive
stories about life with dementia to
challenge these predominant negative
narratives p9 said that so many people
turn their faces to the wall or think
life has ended when they receive a
diagnosis I don't want to continue that
I have other places where I can moan but
I don't think dementia Diaries is a
place to do it some people in the
gathering described a hesitation or a
lectin stew share negative times because
they share the same desire to show that
life goes on with dementia but in
response to this the crowd the gathering
said that people should use the Diaries
to share whatever they wish to whatever
was their authentic concerned priority
or truth and this was a message that was
reinforced throughout the gathering by
facilitators kind of organizers of the
event and diarists as well but we also
found that this was not always 100% the
case so to go into this let me explain
the underlying infrastructure
infrastructure of the system that we
learned about over the course of the
gathering so add iris calls in right
they leave a recording a facilitator an
individual without dementia will listen
to that recording if they have no
concerns about the recording they'll put
it on to the website but if they have a
concern they'll call up that iris
they'll have a discussion with them
um sometimes the diagrams are being
deleted sometimes it ends up being
edited and sometimes the original one
ends up being posted so how do these
facilitators acting as moderators here
decide when to check in with diarists
well one thing moderators looked for was
whether it seemed like something was
being posted in heightened emotion so
heightened emotion p7 described the
experience of being how they had always
been blunt but they've gone more blunt
and irritable with dementia facilitators
of the organization wanted to make sure
that people weren't sharing things that
they would later regret or in particular
things that might be hurtful to other
people so especially things that called
other died wrists by name and they spoke
of a couple times this it happened an
overall diarists welcome these check-ins
from these trusted facilitators with
whom they had built relationships over
time one said it's nice to know that
you're going to soften it in the
gathering and one of the participants
really contextualized the importance of
having someone to check on these
messages I'm seeing that the with a
mission of dementia Diaries we're
spreading our influence in the world the
idea if something wasn't good for one
person then it wasn't going to be good
for everyone else so in summary we can
think about this organization as a case
of health activism where diarists are
engaging in direct action to challenge
the medical paradigm that a sense of
trust built partially in person and over
time supports online sharing that
sharing into here and now is an
accessible approach but with more
accessible ways to share for people to
call you impairment other tensions
emerge such as what to do if someone
wants to share something in this
emotionally heightened state but they
later might regret something that I
think all of us can relate to and we see
this work specifically this strategy of
a trusted person checking in once this
period of heightened emotion has passed
contributing to discussions of enhancing
and decision-making in dementia a topic
of growing interest as care moves in a
more person-centered direction for this
population so I've spoken about three
projects today where we see narratives
of Aging coming through and Technology
design these narratives affecting the
ways that people choose and engage in
daily activities and also the new
opportunities that technology might open
up and also some of the tensions as we
push past them our assumptions of what
people dementia can and can't do in this
talk I've argued that technology can
position older people in ways that they
don't always find welcomed thinking back
to the robotic pets as a recipient of
care rather than someone in a reciprocal
mutually beneficial relationship we're
setting how technologies like augmented
reality might support younger people in
benefiting from learning from the wealth
of knowledge embodied skills and
multi-sensory skills that older people
have built up over time
positioning older people as sources of
wisdom and interactions as mutually
beneficial and we're doing this project
in the context of gardening which makes
for a very intense summer because in
Maryland that's the only time you can do
it so this dementia Diaries
infrastructure where people call in in
the here-and-now to leave a message
that's then posted online works really
well for some people at dementia but
what about as people progress in the
condition so with my student Emma Dixon
on a project funded by the National
Institute on disability independent
living and the and rehabilitation
research we're examining dementia
through the lens of accessibility and
trying to develop interfaces that can
respond to to the variations the
fluctuations that people experience for
example if someone's experiencing a
period of heightened emotion do we want
to defer the decision-making process
until that time has passed
and finally I talked about capturing
authentic voices through organizations
such as des
diaries but once we have these concerns
these priorities of people what do we
actually do with them how can they
better permeate our research and
technology design and also bigger
picture decisions so to answer this
question I'm working with Alicia Pratt
Han a PhD student at the University of
Maryland and we're collaborating with
Mary red norske a dementia rights
advocate and a person living with
dementia and this project has led us in
exciting directions that we definitely
would not have arrived at on our own and
this work is actually part of a larger a
nasa-funded project with Katie seek and
Ben jela at Indiana University
Bloomington where we're focusing on
designing Aging in Place technologies
for older retirees so with that all
thank you for listening to my talk and
really looking forward to any questions
that you have
[Applause]